who are you playing who are you fighting
I think it's Anderson Silva versus Jeff
Kurr oh great
yeah all you have to do is make sure you
check all of his kicks and he'll just
break his own leg yeah done here's the
spider he's pretty happy so I guess the
hardest thing when you're ever when
you're creating a character is choosing
what entrance music yeah I feel like all
the options are for this DMX but it's a
really shitty game yeah it's not the DMX
song you want oh you know they got that
imagined dragon song in there if you
want like a really weak fighter just
like come out to this dumbass song you
know they got some some work to do on
the ski facts let's say this kind of
feels like the we're going to get a
right second time around
totally she's on you were the amount of
time that this game has been shown and
not playable and also the stuff like
that they've been working on it I'm kind
of surprised that it is as bare-bones is
whatever they sheer all the videos and
stuff that's right oh yeah eighty
seconds with Dana White all right great
job here you see fighter remember what I
said I wouldn't work with ei well here
we are
you're the new hoist Gracie it's just at
it looks like presentation-wise it's
it's pretty smashing area yeah totally I
think that's there's some animation
issues that they run into you know just
certain kicks clashing and stuff like
that but for me it's you know like the
anime goes good it's a good looking game
but like the jabs don't snap out the way
you want them to like the input doesn't
it's not very responsive yeah and and
that's that's one of my main problems
with the gameplay for all the problems
I've you know the kind of the ground
game is some of the other stuff they've
done like like that's the thing at the
core it just doesn't feel responsible
well there's a problem that they ran
into the first things right remember
it's always the animation versus sure
pasta so they do they do that swimming
things like where you can't swim through
what you're doing to match up with
what's happened right so it's like yeah
not good yeah but you know it's like I
feel like you know the the EA MMA game
was was pretty awesome
well it was pretty alright they did
their own thing that was different from
CH Q's UFC game but yeah you know I
playing this I would rather just play it
by the time they got into their third
game
what does Bruce Buffer called you when
you when you come in Black Mamba great
but this ps4 is not set to stereo output
so we're not going to hear some of the
channels oh great
by the way one even weirder you looking
pretty caught yeah you know like this is
what I would look like a 2:05 it's
pretty it's kind of terrifying to cut
weight down to 205 you know not eat for
a while
I didn't make a light heavyweight
because I thought I could fight at 205
it was more that I think that's the
division where the action is yeah so
that's usually the you know nice it's
kind of annoying that you kind of find
outside your wake like you can yeah
tossing just yeah just like like just
fudge it like make it work like even in
champion they let you go I believe one
above and one under yeah if you want
it's also that in online they kind of
combine middleweight and light
heavyweight okay and and you know some
of the other divisions they do combine
some of the weight classes so that does
happen here there and if you want to buy
bruce lee what i think you can complete
the game or career mode artist setting
or so really unlock bruce lee guy and
it's like seven bucks i think to buy in
all the weight classes another one all
of them it's like three of them like he
doesn't he does not there's no
heavyweight bruce lee oh yeah you know
like it's four different versions anthem
the to bob sweet
yeah it's that stuff ends up i think
that stuff's lame cuz you end up in the
character select screen and online
matches and stuff and you'll see two
versions the same guy back to back right
the character select screen is already
just this tedious thing in this game
that should have been streamlined and
two loading in general is your spot fun
tokyo tires is here i just randomly
chose some sponsors i don't even
remember
i daily aware and everything that's
smart straight up anyway oh i know you
can put in anywhere logo right on your
junk as well i put the tops logo cuz
that's figure they were sent me free
baseball that brand is hot alright let's
do this boys who's who understand the
fighter son I hope your Jeff Gerstmann
as the otherwise it's gonna get super
Brian are you alright know I swap swap
sites why do you want swap shop we go do
it alright switch anyway now which side
your plan I don't think I'm
oh you don't think you ready okay all
right okay right there right yes yeah
that's right
all right so fighting as Jeff Grossman
is Jeff Grossman and fighting as
Anderson spider Silva Ron McDonald and
that you've been waiting see for a shot
at Weidman's title well yeah getting in
his introductory hugs yeah
sway with you max going straight for the
flying knee as his want of Silva of
Jesus Jeff you're saying we're not
getting all the audio channels
necessarily is like impact one of those
audio channels it could be I don't know
yeah this or hit serve is a weird
mythical machine and there are weird
menus you have to lie to if you want to
get to channel audio out of it for you
know capturing on a video game website
or something like that this have you
seen any low blow stuff happen to this
yet I don't think that's in there I've
seen them in I have a cage no I've seen
the refs like stand people up okay in
some cases worse you know it's like the
key actions kind of stopped can you get
in there and give them the old Suarez
haha
so little shoulder bite just a little
bit of yeah little bit little bit gum on
shoulder look at that no ah no ah hey go
here and now we're making babies some of
the welts unlike swelling and bleeding
and stuff is really well done like you
can really see like thighs getting get a
nice and pink I'm a lot of work and
don't it up the way you like it
guys get like a rock so all bruised up
high I get it following oh my oh it's
the spiders down game is chin you got up
pretty quickly
that's the problem with southern air
he's been knocked at once hey Missouri I
was 14 and 3 when I'm playing but
knocked out Tina white says all right
kid you beat back and then the drop the
next two fights and then they just stop
baby they stop volunteer stuff town
phone stopped ringing and I didn't know
what happened that training camp was
empty everyone said there was some new
guy on the scene and they have caught a
I always says it's my big fists I'm
ready to fight and they sworn listen and
I was deaf
they've Irish MMA practitioner
Conor McGregor in here but right after
they scanned him he got this massive
front tattoo on his chest ogre it's just
not in the game it probably all the
better for ei trying to work out that
legal stuff I did I did see some fun
yeah you had Mario's face tattooed on
his chest oh yeah looking into a lot of
heat lips Chicago really yeah like
getting the rights from individual
artists who made the tattoos oh really
then you end up with some cases where
people get you know licensed things
tattooed like CM Punk has a Pepsi logo
tattooed on himself that was always real
hard Oh Oh Ana de Silva don't let it be
when he sit five seconds can t survive I
take questions from the chaplain
unfortunately my laptop has died so uh
so is under some silver not silver so
yeah and no point was there any sort of
like a head size slider after I like
once you or your game face it's like all
right you're good
you can't really change the hair or
anything in-game oh really like all that
stuff I think happens on the weapon to
the tweaking no no there was limited
tweaks that I could make and most of
them work to the body I was gonna say
this is a pretty diminutive head as a
representation of you yeah no I know I
get it get it looking much bigger at the
head buds oh god I want marked rimmel
style all the time we just want to even
make just dumb characters like I tried
to make a really dumb card yesterday and
I'm sure he had blue dreadlocks and a
red beard that was this size but like
that's as far as I can go it seems like
that if you the key to making really
dumb characters in this game would be to
like go to the website and upload like a
picture of a basketball and say that's
your face and see what happens